un oasis de paix en plein coeur de
port-au-prince
c'est ici que l'écrivaine ml prophète
trouve son inspiration pour écrire c'est
ici que je respire mieux matières
premières s'est fait à haïti moi je
jeûne esthétisme pas la misère mais mais
j'ai besoin d'eux j'ai besoin de ces
traits de ce pays de ce pays et j'ai
besoin aussi d'être dans dans une forme
de combat pour qu'ils changent et des
combats et en haïti l'instabilité
politique la sécurité sans compter des
catastrophes naturelles son plus récent
livre des villages de dieu raconte
l'histoire des quartiers défavorisés
elle est devenue un peu la voix des gens
qu'on écoute pas les gangs les grandes
messes sont nées de la de la faillite de
l'état de la cupidité de deux de ses de
serre paix et aussi parce que des gens
d'argent ont investi dans ce gang là on
profitait de la misère de jeunes
personnes qui vivent dans des quartiers
populaires qui n'ont accès à rien elle
parle d'une voix douce de la dure
réalité du pays entouré de ses livres
ses auteurs préférés elle écrit
l'histoire d'haïti ce pays années de
refus le refus de l' esclavage il faut
que nous gardions cette mémoire là et
que nous construisions à partir de cette
mémoire là et pour tout le monde c'est
plus grande crainte aujourd'hui d'autres
pertes humaines dans des séismes elles
redoutent un tremblement de terre qui va
affecter toute la région de cap haïtien
le nord c'est la citadelle c'est sans
souci ce qu'on appelle le parc national
historique donc ce patrimoine là il est
en danger il faudrait le considérer le
consolider il faudrait énormément
d'argent il faut une politique publique
à cette incertitude physique s'ajoute
l'incertitude politique ceci l'a du
président a été une gifle pour le peuple
haïtien dit elle en fait une humiliation
extraordinaire comme vous entrez chez un
président de la république aussi
contesté qu'il a pu être dans sa chambre
à coucher
vous l'assassiner personne d'autre mais
tu es
alors là ça c'est trop facile c'est trop
facile ça veut dire vous vous les
haïtiens vous n'êtes heures fouillés les
colombiens qui ont été arrêtés ce sont
des seconds couteaux et tout le monde
attend à ce qu on enquête et que les
résultats de l' enquête disent avec
preuves à l'appui qu'ils sont qui est le
commanditaire les communes qui sont les
commanditaires
il faut que l'on sache qui a fait ça
sinon ça va rester comme ne avec ses
plumes elle se bat sur tous les fronts
pour sauver son pays elle a fait le pari
d'y rester coûte que coûte et rêve de
faire de port-au-prince une ville
lumière
elle espère aussi l'arrivée prochaine
d'un véritable leader
il faut qu'il y ait un leader il faut
créer un discours sur ce pays et son
avenir
un leader qui va faire plisser les yeux
dit elle et relever la tête de ce pays
meurtri il faisait beau d'ailleurs qui
sera du canada port au prince haïti